c'est squeeze aujourd'hui on se retrouve
sur squeeze le jeu vidéo a certes un
petit bo a fait un jeu sûr nous voilà
donc merci a toi tu m'en vais je lui ai
tout de suite apparemment ça a l'air
d'être un jour agents au québec elle
s'est pris un bien vite chez moi il faut
que je monte un truc c'est urgent ok
j'arrive voilà le scénario ça mais
n'importe quel scénario me fera plaisir
thibault retrouve cyprien chez lui alors
petite mise en page des contrôles aucun
bonus au thé vert gauche droite c'est
parfait on n'est pas à la fête sans
doute et est mort lol si génial butin
tac aller ok on va tenter à n'importe
quel sort lui a amputé a tenté par haut
up les olé
olé genre très mignon qu'on fait un jeu
pour loin c'est vraiment adorable a
jamais réussi taq taq a sauté la n3
entre les deux pics et qu'il faut sauter
là où je le sais bordel hop là [ __ ]
j'avais réussi là ok et du coup on peut
sauter pour esquiver sa
sortie mdr au nommé pouvoir voir ma
[ __ ] de tête là me dit fier à chaque
fois à chaque mois cette préparation
viala la fin d'un oui oui sortie mdr je
n'ai pas du tout confiance est là bas
non t'es sérieux j'ai toujours détesté
les pics voit la terre dans la vie je
veux pas faire un barbecue je veux
jamais mangé d'olive à l'apéro puisque
la paire des pics donc qui dit picdi
cure dent donc la sortie c'est vraiment
là oh là là mais quelle fourberie des
avocats chez moi qui ai une barque comme
ça je suis pas en confiance ça veut dire
que derrière il ya un truc chelou y
victor ivanov au besoin la justice a pas
du tout à gagner tu es trop fort espace
pour passer au niveau suivant la fois
que oui sa part dans la ville au plus
tard sa part dans le vide déjà atteint
un an j'étais sûr mais c'est la fat ça
veut dire quoi ce panneau mario interdit
de sauter un célibataire du grand écart
dans le doute je vais faire ce qu'il me
dit voilà
donc le mec là te dire interdit de
sauter il peut bailler un panneau où tu
as le droit mais va chier au québec peut
être moins visibles hélas hélas non non
hop le petit saut le petit truc
invisible le deuxième non mais non o o
oh la la olala g
aller trop vite donc si je vais là il ya
des pics et ensuite à deux fois les
directs non la plateforme help elle
bouge vous en faites pas à [ __ ] vous
en faites bonjour je suis jeune j'ai
trouvé la solution il suffit d'attendre
de tomber à plus tard bonjour je suis
valentin et j'ai trouvé la solution il
suffit de gérer gros beauf voilà le
chemin de la victoire alors chaque
l'idéal c'est quoi ça c'est
l'application de bol c'est le logo non
application bardot et du coup oh oh oh
oui aux questions de métro adacore le
logo de l'application kim but quoi
parfait un peu de respect pour ton
créateur un
brave j'esquive le l'autre on est dans
mes chats ni pile dessus hop là haut
elle n'est pas seule elle a appelé
l'application squeeze sur ipad aux plats
aux mondiaux n'est pas lié au lait
biache au compteur mais attends mais je
peux carrément les der le train en fait
annoncé du vide ne
pas dépasser 3 pas les trois pas les
trois
là je sens ça monte ça monte c'est comme
dans une pique en bois rial au début et
d'un coup apple est en ébullition tac
bon
non je crie pas c'est juste je fais mes
voiles les vocalises
aaa
c'est la faute à ma barbe voilà
baby à l'ail qui ce [ __ ] de jeu dans
le cul ya celle à qui the way you move
on the train le trajet perdent à
aa j'en peux plus j'aimerais un jour
sortir de la guerre chatte et léa
sous la serre et pour deux sets ça c'est
une tradition de journalistes montant
des attendez attendez j'ai trouvé le
truc mon gars il suffit juste d'attendre
et normalement ils vont tous passé un
pareil ici j'ai rien à [ __ ]
voilà donc pas du tout il a prévu le
coup leur foire et il est malin et vas-y
mode d'un moi j'arrive tout la raquette
de châtelet les halles elle arrive à
passer les journaux plus [ __ ] on n'est
jamais allé aussi loin
y avait des six à squeeze descous yam
wade squeeze mois où on va et tes genoux
c'est un pillage et pète un câble
d'un mois tu es un menteur tu es un
menteur tu es un menteur tu es un
menteur il aurait pas osé mon gars il
ose la fille de chiens vie de chien et
hubris dévier des quinze vingts ans a
bloqué au niveau suivant on s'en fout on
est passé c'est l'important et salut toi
au revoir oh la la olalala deux boeufs
ok on est bon
au matin au niveau de deux pics qui est
quand même au piquant un excellent pour
battant paul à petit tampon qui fait
plaisir optant peau tempe autant tous et
robes brodées ça qu'on veut le bordel je
compulse de rage lac ont vu leur âge une
nouvelle maladie décrété par les fils de
ton âme et non mais en fait faut juste
que je me barre vite regardez on
m'appelle le ninja m'appelle l'éclair au
chocolat à excellent à s'auto louis
costes udid saef des pays avec des pics
à l'oea
ok on y est
allés maison de cyprien j'arrive cyprien
je sais pas pourquoi aux opus il dit
là il ya des pics qui vont arriver faut
juste sauter haut à mon avis on peut
aller sur sa non il n'y a pas un truc où
se poser là haut si regardez
je savais que ça finirait comme ça
c'est quoi ça va un truc où se cacher là
là là j'arrive cyprien non
au nom dans un moteur
on ira chez toi cyprien tu adores ses
brillants
ou va enfin savoir ce qu'il est urgent
me dire bordel de merde et ce qui est
d'accord pour que ces primaires soient
enfin officiellement renommé en squeeze
guillemets alors on passe comment cette
merde allez
et manon salesse et rien que se
passe-t-il si brillant
non rien ouais
[Applaudissements]
wattao
et voilà j'en porte cette vidéo sur ce
fan game [ __ ] c'était génial quand
même jacques [ __ ] c'est incroyable
c'est la première fois que quelqu'un
fait ça et ça me ça mais mieux je suis
tout ému merci beaucoup thibault
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça vous a
plu comme d'habitude et si vous aussi
vous voulez faire pourquoi pas un petit
joue comme ça sur rail comme thème la
chaîne youtube ou alors un animé une
chanson à fanar bref j'en sais rien et
ce n'est pas en faire un et à me
l'envoyer safar grand plaisir et plus
parfois je vais relayent pour vous
remercier en fait mais c'est d'avoir
regardé le château monde by sa je crois
que j'aime bien
vas-y
[Musique]
oh